hello and welcome to see your plane
Frankie J play them a lot and I don't
know what kind of lines that we have I
can go back to the children for once I
somehow have this feeling he beat me in
a Brea or something I don't know I lost
one game 15 I love it again I still
don't have bad results with this opening
line one thing I can definitely do is
play quick moves
yeah black is going for this night g7
night f7 set up whoa
h4
hmm interesting
he wants to go night-night each fri
guess and so h5 and night h4 I guess
yeah maybe and I was playing on the
queenside huh yeah okay i mean it's it's
possible yeah yeah I had this kind of
stuff it's it looks better but it's not
it's not easy to break down on not at
all
also this is not super consistent with
h4 stuff and then play on the queenside
this should be completely okay now with
the trades
so where are you heading with this I'm
not quite understanding the idea if for
okay oh wait I'm sure actually ridden
the rook if I can white resides yeah and
the chi Goran strikes again play playing
playing all pattern moves and then the
point blonde as a rogue yeah well it is
a very it's a very em on sturdy
structure as I thought I so thought why
do I did Nico a try this was the idea
right and I wasn't sure what to do g5 i
think i will put it on the plate this
problem i thought that he might do this
but i can still cover it I mean this is
not leading to too much here for why
that I can go okay next I know it looks
ugly but yeah and I don't think that
this leads to much it looks good yeah
like on the surface for Wyatt but you
simply don't get much even here I'm
completely fine i go 98 King goes to e7
Bishop c8 ultimately I'll kick the rock
out and then we play a minor piece
ending which is okay for black and
sticky n okay fo as a blonde of it what
should you do my computer wants to play
play this kind of move and I go here
maybe here should see age with whatever
yeah Bishop b6 is also now possible
probably bishop there should be six I
will I will play anyway and so like this
white plays something i don't know this
and i will probably probably trade this
dance this and then shoot for this night
c7.r okay six
i played this so many times i think
black has nothing to fear Him he's got
f5 as a long-term idea and you can expel
the rook the problem of this line is
when when white keep some more pieces on
the board and to try some Kings I'd
assault this is not so dangerous playing
on the cup inside ok well thanks for
watching